[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
good morning to the students of the
class of 2017 and our parents their
families and friends welcome to the 360
commencement of Yale University we
gather to recognize the extraordinary
accomplishments of all of you who work
so hard to complete your programs of
study we salute your efforts your
diligence your talent and your intellect
we also join you in expressing gratitude
for all who have supported you in these
endeavors your families their friends
your teachers all the other members of
the Yale Committee in keeping with the
tradition of this occasion I now call
the University chaplain to offer an
education
my beloved Yale family I invite you to
join me in the spirit of Prayer Almighty
and loving creator you are the force
that lights the Stars the architects of
every cell the source of all truths we
stand in the dazzling beauty of this
morning and many expressions of one
living mystery a mystery beyond all
telling as students of your handiwork we
have gathered here from throughout the
earth with excluded ambitions and have
been blessed at this place of light and
truth with the freedom to let them grow
our God of all generations you are the
guardians of where we are going and who
we are
humming we share this beautiful but
making world we who looked the same Sun
in the same room are people called to
communal restoration as we prepare to
take leave of this place mainly exude an
intelligence that is inspired by justice
guided by tenderness may God bless us we
are one family
from this moment on fill our hearts with
an imaginative very one it stirred us
become a vibrant and living examples of
Shalom Salaam of Sharkey of peace as one
people let it day amen
mr. president I the honor to prevent
candidates for the bachelor's degree in
Yale College for the degree of Bachelor
of Arts 891 in number and for the degree
of Bachelor of Science 425 in number
they have been recommended by the
Faculty of Yale College and approved by
the corporation I now ask you by your
official act to confer upon them E
degrees
[Applause]
by the authority vested in me I confer
upon you the bachelors degrees in Yale
College as designated by the Dean and
admit you to all their rights and
responsibilities
[Applause]
mr. president I have the honor to
present candidates for degrees in the
School of Architecture
[Applause]
for the degree Master of Architecture 64
in number and for the degree Master of
Environmental Design to a number they
have been recommended by the Faculty of
the school and approved by the
corporation I now ask you by your
official act to confer upon them these
degrees by the authority vested in me I
confer upon you the degrees in
architecture and design as designated by
the Dean and admit you to all their
rights and responsibilities
[Applause]
mr. president I have the honor to
present candidates for the degrees in
the school of art for the degree of
Master of Fine Arts 59 in number they
have been recommended by the Faculty of
the school approved by the corporation I
now ask you by your official act to
confer upon them this degree by the
authority vested in me I confer upon you
the degree in March as designated by the
Dean and admit you to all its rights and
responsibilities
[Applause]
mr. president I have the honor to
present candidates for degrees in the
School of Drama where the reciprocating
drama won in number for the degree of
master of my art fifty in number and for
the degree of Doctor of Fine Arts to a
number they have been recommended by the
Faculty of the school and approved by
the corporation I now ask you by your
official act to confer upon them these
degrees five-year 30 vested in me I
confer upon you the certificate and
degrees in drama as designated by the
Dean and admit you to all their rights
and responsibilities
[Applause]
yeah
mr. president I have the honor to
present candidates for degrees in the
School of Music for the artists diploma
one in number for the degree of Master
of Music seventy-nine and number for the
degree of Master of Musical Arts 26 in
number and for the degree of Doctor of
Musical Arts 8 and number they have been
recommended by the faculty in the school
and approved by the corporation I now
ask you by your official act to confer
upon them these degrees by the authority
vested in me I confer upon you the
diploma and degrees in music as
designated by Dean and admit you to all
their rights and responsibilities
[Applause]
mr. president I have the honor to
present candidates for degrees in the
School of Nursing degree after science
Anarchy 89 and number and for the degree
of Doctor of Nursing 15 in number they
have been recommended by the Faculty of
the school and approved by the
corporation I am now ask you by your
official act to confer upon them be
brief at the authority vested in me I
confer upon you the degrees in nursing
and designated by the Dean and admit you
to all their rights and responsibilities
[Applause]
[Applause]
mr. president I am the honor to present
candidates for degrees in the School of
Forestry and environmental study for the
degrees for the degree of Master of four
three seven in number for the degree of
Master forest science foreign number for
the degree of master environmental
management 107 and number and for the
degree of master of environmental
science xx section number they have been
recommended by the Faculty of the school
and approved by the corporation I now
ask you by your official act to confer
upon them these degrees by the authority
vested in me I confer upon you the
degrees in forestry and environmental
studies and designated by the Dean and
admit you to all their rights and
respond to them
[Applause]
president mr. president I had the honor
to present candidates for degrees in the
School of Management for the degree of
Master of Business Administration 373 in
number for the degree of Matt and then
master of Advanced Management City and
number they have been recommended by the
faculty in the school and approved by
the corporation I now ask you by your
official act to confer upon them these
degrees by the authority vested in me I
confer upon you the degrees in
management and designated by the Dean
and it made use of all their rights and
responsibilities
[Applause]
mr. president I have the honor to
present candidates for degree in the
Divinity School for degree of Master of
Arts in religion seventy-five in number
for the degree of Master of Divinity
maybe two in number and for the degree
of masters in theology eight in number
they have been recommended by the
Faculty of the school and approved by
the corporation I now ask you by your
official act to confer upon them these
degrees by the authority vested in me I
confer upon you the degrees in religion
divinity and theology as designated by
the Dean and minions of all their rights
and responsibilities
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
mr. president I have the honor to
present candidates for degrees in the
law school for the degree of Juris
Doctor 213 in number with a degree of
Master of Laws 20 for a number and for
the degree of Doctor of the science of
law for a number when they had been
recommended by the faculty in the school
and approved by the corporation I shall
ask you by your official act to confer
on them these degrees by the authority
vested in me I shall confer upon you the
degrees in the law school when
designated by the Dean and shall then
have in you to all their life
[Applause]
mr. president I have the honor to
present candidates for the degrees in
the graduate school for degree of Master
of Science 199 in number for the degree
of Master of Arts 257 in number for the
degree of Master of advanced science 3
in number and for the degree of master
of philosophy 372 in number they have
been recommended by the Faculty of the
school and approved by the corporation I
now ask you by your official act to
confer upon them these degrees by the
authority vested in me I confer upon you
the degrees of the Graduate School as
designated by the Dean and give you to
all their rights and responsibilities
[Applause]
mr. president I have the honor to
present candidates for the juries in the
School of Public Health for the degree
of master public health 151 in number
they have been recommended by the
Faculty of the school and approved by
the corporation I now ask you by your
fish lacking her paw them this degree
five-year thorny vested in me I confer
upon you the degree in public health as
designated by the Dean and admit you to
all its rights and responsibilities
[Applause]
mr. president I have the honor to
prevent candidates the degrees in the
School of Medicine
[Applause]
for the degree of Master of Medical
Science 20 a number when they have been
recommended by the Faculty of the school
and approved by the corporation I shall
ask you by your official act to confer
upon them this degree for the degree of
master of health science 36 in number
for the degree of Doctor of Medicine 89
in number and for the certificate in
global medicine 4 in number they have
been recommended by the Faculty of the
school and approved by the corporation I
now ask you by your official act to
confer upon them these degrees by the
authority vested in me I shall confer
the degree in medical science and do
confer upon you the certificate and
degrees in health science medicine and
global medicine as designated by the
Dean and admit you to all their rights
and responsibilities
[Music]
[Applause]
- carisi a colleague of those are brown
Phyllis opioid are porous numerous try
Kent a sub to be in tight race CD - ho
Akbar Khan Attila Sophie I REM quake at
a synoptic Academical illustrate a
Probot eaten hey da na a robo LOL unhook
grotto admit us Secunda analogous
moonquake university' this nose fly was
a guru philosophy i doctores anita world
this way little comb hawk diplomat a
gorilla earthquake ingot Aki's cry and
walk on harem spec on quintero milk
studies Palicki tear absolutist a go
places who arrested hottest was an
animal yo bail
somewhere a at
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we will now proceed to the awarding of
honorary degrees the eight individuals
we honor this morning serve and examples
view our graduates to encourage you to
aspire to excellence and to value those
elements of human character that they
invited creativity curiosity discipline
integrity and a passion for social
justice their presence here also honors
you you graduate today and all of us who
are here to salute you
I will now as is customary call upon the
Provost to present the candidates for
honorary degrees mr. president I have
always represent the candidates for
honorary degrees for the degree of
Doctor of Laws Sean Forbes Carey public
service
[Applause]
ever since your Yale college days you
have worked to fulfill your rights and
responsibilities toward your fellow
citizens after graduation you enlisted
in the u.s. Navy and served two tours of
duty in Vietnam returning with a Silver
Star Bronze Star for valor in combat and
three purple hearts you spoke your
conscience to Congress and spoke up for
your fellow veterans helping sound the
Vietnam Veterans of America as a u.s.
senator and then as Secretary of State
you have served this country and its
people for over three decades
esteemed statesmen in recognition of a
lifetime of service and leadership we
are honored to present you with your
second Yale degree the Doctor of Laws
[Applause]
for the degree of Doctor of Letters
googy want younger author author
playwright activist and scholar you have
shown us the power of words to change
the world
you have written in English and in your
Kenyan language Kikuyu you have worked
in prison cells and in exile and you
have survived assassination attempts all
to bring attention to the plight of
ordinary people in Kenya and around the
world brave words myth for breaking down
barriers for showing us the potential of
literature to incite change and promote
justice for helping us decolonize our
minds and open them to new ideas we are
privileged to award you this degree of
Doctor of Letters
[Applause]
for the degree of doctor of music Marin
Alsop conductor as the music director of
the Baltimore Symphony Orchestra and the
Sao Paulo city orchestra you connect
audiences around the world with great
music your career is studied with firsts
you were the first woman to receive the
crucible
cassette who did it be conducting prize
on a tango music letter the first
principal conductor of the Colorado
Symphony the first female music director
of a major American Orchestra and the
first first woman to conduct the last
night of prom you are also committed to
sharing the joy of music widely orts
kids a program you started in Baltimore
has provided music education to over
1,000 at-risk children helping them
learn not only new skills but discover
new passions as well
magnificent maestro yellow joins vivace
in a chorus of appreciation as it
proudly awards you the degree of music
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
for the degree of Doctor of Laws Sean
our Lewis
from Freedom Riders to statement you
have championed civil rights and public
service for six decades your faith
beatings violence and intonation with
steadfast non-violence from the enman
Pettis bridge in Selma Alabama to the
halls of the US Congress
you have been the conscience of our
nation guiding us in the great
unfinished march toward equality civil
rights and human dignity devoted
champion of America and of all of its
people in recognition on a lifetime of
bold action and inspiring results we are
honored to present you with this Doctor
of Laws degree
[Applause]
so the degree of Doctor of Engineering
and Technology Owen Marc Jacobs engineer
and philanthropist we are living in an
era of unprecedented change technology
has revolutionized our world allowing
people to communicate faster and more
effectively than ever before
your veil meter of this data revolution
digital wireless technology you
developed is used in hundreds of
millions of cell phones around the world
profoundly altering how we communicate
and how we live our lives as a
philanthropist you see who sees beyond
science you continue to celebrate human
ingenuity through the arts culture and
education wizard of engineering for your
visionary leadership and innovative
ideas we are honored to bestow on you
this degree of Doctor of Engineering and
Technology
[Applause]
the degree of Doctor of Science for
media Bodmin norovirus
[Applause]
by saying a tiny almost invisible right
word you are unlocking the secrets of
the human brain your exploration of a
modest but nobly titled c.elegans verb
will help us understand how two genes
and environments interact when people
make decisions in addition to your
path-breaking research your leadership
of the national brain initiative will
help other pioneering scientists advance
our understanding of the mysteries
locked in the brains 86 billion neurons
with amazement and appreciation for your
work in neurobiology which benefits the
entire human family we proudly confer
upon you the degree Doctor of Science
[Applause]
for the degree of doctor of social
science Jessie little doe ved linguist
your commitment to the past present and
future of indigenous communities has
made an enduring contribution to the
life of your people as a co-founder of a
womp
uh no AG language reclamation projects
you are working through research and
education to preserve and revitalize a
language once spoken by tens of
thousands in southeastern New England
your work has helped us has helped reach
into the past and reclaim what has been
lost connecting all of us to your shared
humanity citizen of a musky Wampanoag
tribe and representative of the Native
American tribes throughout our nation as
we stand here on what was one native
lands I am humbled to present you with
its doctor of social science degree
[Applause]
and for the degree of doctor of music
even Morris nodes in the u.s. set1
the music of your mind has brought joy
to millions you told us to climb our
hands just a little bit louder and the
whole world clap along a Rock and Roll
Hall of Famer with 25 Grammy Awards and
an Oscar you have already turned to us
in a key of mice while working to help
the poor sick and marginalized whether
you were living for the city or speaking
up for misrepresented people you brought
us to higher grounds with your incisive
protest phones and you got the whole
country to sing happy birthday to dr.
King helping establish a national
holiday in his honor wars are fought the
appreciated of your irresistible unit
and your forefingers Unitarian effort
we're proud to present you with this
doctor of music memory fine feel
delivers it's yours
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
Oh
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I invite you to join in prayer God
unmeasured by time but marker of our
time unapproachable in space but present
to us unknown in essence but
recognizable in beauty unmatched in
grace but a holder of justice grant
longevity to those whose brief time here
is fulfilled watch over them wherever
they may be and bless those in our midst
who now need medical help make these
graduates known like our honorees by
their service to all fill their hearts
with sensitivity to the needs of all who
do not enjoy our privileges thank you
for those who have given these graduates
their past for this place we call Yale
open our eyes the beauty of our world
and our responsibilities to it transform
us with grace so that we may work for
the well-being of all all men
[Music]
good
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you